Léa Salamé Christophe Dechavanne et
Philippe cabri vert comment ça va mes
chéries vous êtes ton fort pour pour
samedi
on est bien vous êtes bien alors
je sais que je savais que ça allait te
plaire je savais que ça allait faire tu
vois ça fait longtemps aussi non il a
payé la vie non non
je te dis que si pas du tout je te dis
je te connais en suivant
comment ça s'est passé raconte-nous ton
histoire écoute ça s'est passé que
Laurent Ruquier comme tu le sais c'est a
décidé d'arrêter qu'est-ce tu fais tu
dis bonjour à tous
je vais te sortir hein pardon d'abord
oui oui bien sûr oui quelle question
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
toi aussi tu viens quand tu veux bien
entendu je sais alors Léa comment s'est
passé cette rencontre avec Christophe
parce que et ben c'est je l'ai draguais
non c'est vrai et oui c'est moi qui l'ai
appelé c'est moi qui l'a appelé direct
a décidé d'arrêter voilà je le regrette
mais je respecte la décision et ben on
s'est retrouvé avec mon producteur on
s'est dit qui on a envie qui on a envie
de prendre
et pour dire la vérité c'est mon produit
en fait on a écrit trois noms chacun sur
un petit papier mon producteur et moi et
on s'est vu et on a donné notre liste de
nom que je dévoilerai pas et tu peux
nous dire les deux autres
je dirais pas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ah ouais Léa tu vas vite hein
il y avait le producteur aussi
producteur et donc c'est la première
fois que tu rencontres qu'est-ce que tu
lui dis c'est quoi tes pronostics on a
parlé de tout de rien il m'a fait trois
vannes Jerry ça a duré 2h quand même
pas mal
[Applaudissements]
et donc ouais 3 Vannes et après on s'est
fait chier
et vous êtes dit quoi tu as dit tu as
dit oui tout de suite
ça marchait visiblement ça s'est passé
c'est un petit peu de mes animaux c'est
un peu comme vous c'est que c'est que
c'est tout de suite ou pas en fait bah
oui c'est souvent comme ça et alors ça a
été tout de suite moi je suis parti là
j'ai appelé Régis j'ai dit moi je suis
content et elle régit le producteur
voilà voilà
on parle encore et puis voilà et on
parle encore c'est incroyable
vous enregistrez quand vendredi soir
vendredi soir alors personnellement je
ne sais pas si c'est moi mais moi
j'entends très mal alors alors
les gars vous allez enregistrer tout le
temps le vendredi soir parce que là
c'est Rocha en plus
exactement elle est quand même
incroyable on a des Juifs écoute chérie
non mais c'est magnifique ça alors il y
aura Laurence Ferrari je vais regarder
Jean-Luc Mélenchon je vais regarder
Nicky doll je vais regarder Marco bouygi
je vais regarder plus que regarder il y
a de Max j'adore le Père Mathieu je vais
regarder Cindy brûlant
je vais regarder Jean-Paul Roux je vais
éviter
je peux pas le virer voilà il le sait il
m'a dit on ne dit pas ça
allait la voir on est le droit de
l'aimer chacun qui veut moi je peux pas
le blairer de toute façon j'espère le
croiser bientôt les chéris
je peux pas bien toi excusez-moi tu
l'aimes bien toi et je vais vous poser
question moi
[Applaudissements]
un petit peu quand même un petit peu bon
vous êtes heureux de vous retrouver tous
c'est vrai franchement en tout cas je
vous dis je sens que vous entendez bien
je sens que c'est pas fake je te jure
c'est vrai
histoire avec l'air contente aussi
d'avoir réussi à convaincre Philippe
parce que Philippe cave rivière
Canteloup pendant très longtemps l'année
dernière l'année de la présidentielle il
a explosé à la fois sur on est en direct
sur RTL tous les matins et je dois dire
qu'il a eu 1000 propositions à la fois
je l'ai appelé Philippe hein
il a eu la gentillesse
tu as vu comment je l'ai senti il y a 2
ans que je t'ai appelé en équipe
mais il m'a dit il m'a dit il m'a dit
combien j'ai dit non laisse tomber reste
chez restaurant est en a pas voulu que
tu restes avec l'air Laurent j'ai mis 20
jours au mois de juillet à l'appeler
tous les jours je me trouvais une excuse
pour l'appeler pour lui dire je continue
avec Léa
très dur c'est un truc que je déteste
faire dans ce métier il a été d'une
grande élégance il m'a dit vas-y je je
suis toujours comme ça avec les gens que
je lance et c'était original c'est vrai
que il a lancé un vieux les gens lancent
des jeunes et en lançant il a lancé un
peu un vieux et c'est le premier à faire
ça dans le métier
ma grande élégance
Léa Laurent a dit que si il était encore
tout seul il serait resté
qu'est-ce que tu veux que je te dise
j'ai déjà répondu moi j'aurais aimé
continues avec lui
je le dis et je le répète
j'ai compris Laurent quand tu es quand
tu es seul depuis pendant des années et
qu'on te demande de quoi animer avec
quelqu'un franchement c'est compliqué je
te dis déjà il a été je trouve qu'il a
eu l'élégance de dire oui au départ et
de dire je vais le tenter après c'est
vrai que c'est pas senti dans la
co-animation Laurent et je peux le
comprendre tout à fait mais voilà mais
c'est vrai que il y a quatre ans il m'a
invité à déjeuner à la fin de mon n’est
pas couché il m'a proposé de revenir
qu'au présenter avec lui on n'est pas
couché je vous assure que c'est parce
que c'est vrai que tu avais commencé
avec Laurent moi j'avais commencé avec
lui
heureuse de sa chroniqueuse j'étais
heureuse de sa compréhensatrice moi je
l'ai regardé faire pendant un an j'ai
appris on le regardant c'est un très bon
j'aurais pu continuer avec lui plusieurs
années je peux comprendre qu'au bout de
17 ans il est pas en vie ça le saoule
d'attendre 17 ans
et voilà après je il a décidé ça et et
voilà tu te respecte mais j'aurais
continué
cette case il est dit je ne suis pas
heureux à deux donc sous-entendu si je
suis seul je reste est-ce que vous vous
êtes dit peut-être une seconde ok c'est
pas moi de récupérer la case puisqu'on
était pas heureux à deux je m'en vais et
je te laisse la case moi honnêtement je
l'ai dit très clairement à la chaîne moi
j'ai dit sur la chaîne qui a décidé mais
vous savez moi j'ai essayé de le
convaincre de rester moi je lui ai dit
ce serait cool de rester parce que là
l'émission
peut-être ne pas vous dites moi je vais
faire autre chose et garde ta garde ça
se passe pas comme ça ça peut se passer
comme ça quand même non
c'est une belle phrase moi j'ai essayé
de le convaincre de rester parce qu'on
lançait ce truc là tes missions
commencer vous l'avez fait Cyril vous
l'avez fait genre mission avec Laurent
je me suis régalé et vous avez dit à
l'époque ils étaient un duo qui marche
donc c'était voilà mais c'est vrai que
là je pense que
sincèrement c'est vrai que voilà quand
quelqu'un arrive moi je n'aurais pas
qu'on mette voilà quelqu'un à côté tout
de suite attendez deux trois mois mais
c'est vrai que voilà et c'est vrai que
là avec Christophe j'ai l'impression que
le duo est naturel
ces émissions de c'est une émission de
Léa alors moi je suis juste bâton de
berger compose là
on va me poser je suis un peu comme un
invité principale vous voyez on va me
poser comme ça et tu réagis à tout au
dessus
oui je travaille un peu quand même bah
oui forcément on se connaît bien tu as
dit oui tout de suite à cette position
c'est j'ai été 30 ans le patron des
émissions ça m'amuse beaucoup de voir si
d'ailleurs c'est sûr que oui vu comment
s'entend de tenir une position de
seconde je m'en fous en fait
de Chavanne c'est très étonnant moi je
commence à bosser avec lui et il est
vachement dans la transmission en fait
il m'appelle il me dit tu devrais faire
ça tu devrais faire ci enfin il est il
est généreux
[Rires]
il est producteur il a son œil et ça
m'aide énormément et ça me pose aucun
souci mais vraiment vraiment ouais tu es
heureux
moi je vais ranger mes cartons j'étais
prêt à mettre les mains dans la terre
avec Monsieur
pourquoi non c'est fini
je m'entends très bien avec eux j'ai des
projets avec eux si si impératrice mais
alors ça ça va être difficile
tu as des projets avec TF1 oui un
producteur
j'ai des projets avec la maison ici je
sais ici car jeunes avec les animaux
collaborateurs et je fais ça vraiment
mais avec un engouement de de gamins
parce que c'est nouveau et puis comme
c'était un peu plié l'histoire dans ma
tête
heureusement parce que sinon j'ai pas
gratter à la porte comme un chat pendant
8 ans
tu veux que je te dise la vérité je te
jure que tu as changé de tête mais c'est
parce que je te jure Christophe tu es tu
saurais ouais je le trouve
toujours Christophe mais je suis détendu
du bruit je pense que c'est vrai c'est
tout va changer je te jure Christophe je
me sens très bien parce que ça y est je
suis heureux comme un fou d'aller faire
ce truc là j'ai une patronne c'est la
bosse mais si si si c'est pour ça que ça
joue c'est fou c'est le deal du départ
mon chou c'est comme ça vous avez vu ce
qu'il dit j'ai une patronne c'est la
boss oui
on est au courant
j'ai une patronne c'est la bosse Léa
quand tu as dit quelque chose ça fait le
doux c'est pas on discute pas
non je pense pas non mais tu es heureuse
toi moi je suis hyper heureuse
honnêtement j'aurais pas pu rêver
meilleur
trio
que ces deux-là les deux je l'ai trouvé
extrêmement talentueux lui c'est un
animateur fou incroyable tu seras là
toutes les missions Philippe
qui reste à la fin
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
franchement bravo ça me fait plaisir
d'un truc très important et en fait et
on est vraiment on est très rigolant le
pilote c'est très bien passé on a fait
une vraie émission
de la semaine dernière et ça c'est
incroyable
c'est sûr mais je vous jure je croyais
pas que ça allait les deux ça vous savez
on essaie le truc on y va avec humilité
on sait pas moi je sais pas si je suis
capable d'être une année mais si je sais
pas tu te rappelles on se voyait dans
les couloirs
elle était dans les couteaux rares de
cnews elle était déjà très talentueuse
et elle m'a dit elle m'avait dit ouais
Laurent Ruquier m'a appelé
pour être et je t'avais dit chroniqueuse
et tu m'avais dit vas-y part
moi je suis pas sûr que ça va marcher
mais on tente le truc si ça va être quoi
l'émission C'est quoi c'est un taux qui
aura des invités
son arrivée à Paris Match à sucer des
remous et elle se tait on a envie de
l'entendre on entend ce qu'elle a à dire
il y a tous les autres moi je trouve que
c'est bien en ce moment
donc on est plutôt content et après
voilà on y va ça marche ça marche on
arrive en challenger il y a déjà les
taux qui sont déjà bien installés vous
êtes là à côté de
vous avez quoi comme espoir d'audience
parce que c'est important quand même
l'audience
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
qui va regarder théoriquement donc ça
nous en fait
moi je à quelle heure vous allez
démarrer
à quelle heure vous allez démarrer
l'émission 23h10 là 23h10 il y a quoi
avant vous Cyril Féraud un nouveau truc
ça c'est important
le lendemain matin vous êtes le truc je
vous ai dit record de danse oui
sur les ménagers
je vous dirais je te dirai je t'enverrai
un petit texto parce que je vais suivre
je serai en direct mais vous avez
demandé à ce qui raccourcissent les les
bandes annonces tout ça entre votre
émission et l'émission parce que à
l'époque c'était une année pour euh tu
finissais le prime time tu avais 10
minutes de bande-annonce de truc
franchement comme nous là on est 18h
c'est pareil tu vois c'est ça bah je te
dis il faut pas que l'argent attention
attention
Philippe ça va être quoi tes deux
chroniques ça va être une rubrique
politique et puis après une rubrique un
peu fourre-tout société sport ce que je
fais un petit peu
j'adore je vais regarder ce sera à
quelle heure à peu près pour ce sera en
début d'émission la première la
politique et après j'interviens juste
après le débat politique avec toutes les
missions c'est le seul Christophe c'est
le seul c'est comme voilà comme à
l'époque il y avait ma fille un invité
c'est que je sais pas le faire là par
exemple
non tu vois je mets pas mais ça peut
être un sniper bienveillant et efficace
c'est un intervenant mais invité
permanent c'est bon tout le temps c'est
moi qui ai trouvé ce truc là je trouve
je suis très bien dans cette position
une fois que je trouve une bonne
position
sinon je fais ça pour le kiffe en vrai
en vrai et pour refuser aussi comment
pour être en espérant rebondir aussi sur
un prêt sur notre démarche d'animateur
oui mais comme chroniqueur c'est pas
pareil
vous n'êtes pas animateur non plus vous
avez dit c'est la bosse oui mais je suis
je suis très présent hein vous auriez
peut-être vraiment accepté ça quand vous
étiez pas dans une traversée du désert
et là mais c'est pas une traversée du
désert
non mais c'est pas une conversation
oui c'était fini
tu vois mais non c'était de toute façon
ma carrière c'est ça comme hein donc
voilà là c'est école
c'était un peu long comme ça et tout
d'un coup l'embellie a un coup de fil
maintenant tu sais si si mon père si ma
tante on allait
vraiment donc oui j'ai une question pour
Christophe une question sur la télé
vraiment renouvelé le genre du Talk Show
alors je sais pas comment le prendre
c'est une blague au deuxième degré pas
du tout parce que
Drucker de Chavannes et Foucault voilà
sur le reste voilà c'était ma question
vous qui avez renouvelé le genre
aujourd'hui cyril a réinventé le talk
show est-ce que pour vous c'est le
meilleur animateur aujourd'hui
mais chacun des personnalités chacun
fait ce qu'il fait cette émission
n'existe pas ailleurs tout à l'heure en
revenant en voiture j'ai regardé le
système je savais même pas que tu
faisais tu vois et j'ai regardé il était
au taquet il faisait le couillon partout
il faisait chaud pour régulier comme des
bossus bon voilà c'est c'est il est très
fort on n'est pas pareil mais il est
très très fort voilà
je serai sans doute pas capable de
mettre un costume trois pièces avec des
poils arrête tu peux le faire tu peux le
faire tu veux toucher
je l'ai souvent dit c'est moi c'est
Christophe qui m'a donné envie de faire
je le suis je rentrais moi pour voir
Christophe c'était pour moi c'était
parce que voilà c'est il pouvait faire
beaucoup avec rien et c'est ça
va être avec beaucoup de compliments
mais je suis très inquiet pour les je ne
crois pas beaucoup à cette émission à
cause de ça pourquoi le lion qui dort a
toujours ses dents et c'est de qui c'est
de qui ça je suis de mes Christophe
Dechavanne le lion qui dort à tout le
monde mais on le voit même ce soir
depuis un quart d'heure c'est lui qui
parle il prend la place c'est la star
c'est un animateur pardon je le dis avec
toute l'admiration que j'ai pour vous
pour moi vous êtes le meilleur mais
effectivement et le côté le côté on a
pris un tigre on va en faire un petit
chat dans un coin qui va non en vrai je
suis désolé mais très rapidement soit
elle sera pas heureux soit il va vous
bouffer Léa parce que je le dis je ne
crois pas du tout à ce côté vous l'avez
déjà dit que vous l'aviez déjà dit je me
suis dit décidément ce garçon dit encore
chroniqueur permanent c'est inconnu
pour ne pas dire chroniqueur pour vexer
personne pas
même mais où est-ce que j'ai mais on le
voit ce soir Christophe et moi ça me
ravie je vous aime mais on entend que
vous ne voit que vous vous êtes au
milieu c'est vous la star mais c'est Léa
mais vous n'écoutez pas qu'on est à part
si Christophe je dis que vous vous
n'êtes pas un second Christophe vous ne
l'avez jamais été vous aurez
je pense que regarde prends ce que veut
dire ce que veut dire Mathieu parce que
moi j'ai co-présent avec Christophe
Christophe il prend de l'espace il prend
il prend la lumière après il est
généreux donc ça c'est pas un premier
mais effectivement il faut quand même il
faut il faut que Léa s'arme non j'ai pas
besoin moi je vais vous dire je vais
vous répondre si vous me permettez
j'ai eu plein de gens comme vous qui
m'ont dit mais tu es complètement folle
il va te bouffer etc et qui m'ont dit
mais pourquoi tu as pas pris comme tous
les autres animateurs donc qui prennent
des fleurs valoir et je trouve
[Applaudissements]
elle m'a montré quand elle a dit tous
les autres animateurs la rentrée
donc moi je trouve qu'il est phénoménal
s'il me bouffe comme vous dites qu'il me
bouffe je m'en fous moi je viens
m'amuser essayer de donner du sens dans
cette émission là qu'il se passe des
moments de télé moi je suis une
journaliste avant d'être une animatrice
donc je ferai mon job de journaliste je
vais essayer d'être marrante aussi de me
déboutonner un petit peu j'ai du temps
pour arriver je suis très heureuse qu'il
soit là il a tu as raison Valérie il
prend la place
vous aidera dans la mécanique
c'est pas malheureux comme vous dites et
si me bouffe bon vous serez content vous
direz je voulais bien vivre
c'est pas ça c'est pas ça on tente un
truc on est hyper heureux on y va
bienveillant on y va tous les trois on
est content de le faire ça marche ça
marche ça marche pas ben on viendra chez
vous dire bah vous avez raison Mathieu
et dans un état d'esprit que on est
vraiment content peut-être vous
connaissez pas l'état d'esprit dans
lequel je suis
avec toute l'admiration que j'ai pour
vous je suis en train de dire que c'est
parce que pour moi vous êtes là et que
vous serez pas être là et quand vous
avez joué c'est compliqué d'aller jouer
à Maubeuge pardon Laurent Ruquier était
une machine de guerre aussi Eliane s'est
jamais fait bouffer par Laurent Ruquier
jusqu'à maintenant Christophe était avec
quelqu'un que ce soit sur une caissier
ou carmener c'est de la personne était
vraiment dans la même configuration
[Musique]
son rôle de son nouveau
là je vais dans une émission qui n'est
pas la mienne comme aujourd'hui je suis
dans une émission qui n'est pas la
mienne et je souhaite que ça marche on
est très content
tu vas être bien avec les deux c'est
pour ça que je les laisse si ça se
plante je dirais mais c'est eux
je le sens bien samedi soir je vous dis
je sens bien je sens un score pas mal je
sens que ça va être bien je sens que ça
va le but surtout c'est de faire une
émission dont on soit content lundi vous
vous disiez pas on s'est fait chier ou
c'était
nulle
je sais pas bon ça on verra lundi il
faudra se verra Gilbert
Delphine oui alors justement j'ai une
question pour vous vous avez fait
beaucoup de co-animation d'après vous
qui est le meilleur présentateur et le
moins bon avec lequel vous avez
travaillé ou bien ça c'est bien qu'elle
balance un peu alors le meilleur je sais
pas si c'est le meilleur mais celui qui
marche avec moi parce qu'en fait une
co-animation c'est comme dans l'amour
c'est comme une relation sexuelle ça
marche il y a pas de bon coup moi j'y
crois pas je pense que parfois ça marche
avec certaines personnes et parfois avec
d'autres je vous dirais spontanément ça
vous surprendra pas Nicolas de Morand
avec qui je présente la matinale de
France Inter et depuis 5 et mon mari je
les ai présenté parce que Nicolas
Demorand est venu faire le pilote
amicalement il se connaissait pas
[Musique]
Christophe je vais une question à vous
poser concernant la télé votre carrière
je vous admire énormément
[Rires]
en tout cas quand vous avez animé des
émissions très connues souvent ça a duré
que deux ans pourquoi est-ce que ça va
durer deux ans par exemple c'est encore
mieux l'après-midi Coucou c'est nous un
tout petit peu plus longtemps vous vous
épuisez à ce moment-là vous en avez
marre et vous avez envie de changer et
déjà deux ans ce serait top
50 donc là vous avez été le plus grand
enfin c'est là c'est ce qui m'a fait
débuter en tout cas voilà alors c'est le
moment dit je l'ai fait 4 ans que c'est
nous je l'ai fait 3 ans mais j'aurais
pas dû arrêter mais tu as raison je
n'aurais pas dû arrêter vous avez tout à
fait raison je serai peut-être encore
mais j'ai arrêté pour voilà pour plein
de raisons j'avais pas envie de me
mécaniser je voulais faire autre chose à
une période je me suis dit je vais
peut-être tu vois j'ai pêché
c'est-à-dire peut-être quand à la fois
une quotidienne je me suis dit je vais
faire une Hebdo la boîte va marcher
aussi bien puis je
[Musique]
moi j'étais je voulais faire question
pour un champignon parce que j'avais
jamais fait de de de jeux et je me suis
dit tiens je vais faire du jeu et si je
viens le père se casse la jambe ce qu'il
n'a jamais fait j'aimerais bien faire ça
le temps qu'il serait pas et puis
finalement on m'a dit ce que tu veux
faire la roue de la fortune j'ai fait
ouais six mois si vous voulez refaire de
l'actu sur TMC je crois qu'il y avait un
projet de Talk Show à un moment qui a eu
lieu ouais bon personne pas beaucoup de
monde l'a vu et c'était bien l'idée
était très bonne vous savez que moi
c'est pour ça que je l'ai pris parce que
au-delà l'animateur phénoménal j'ai
remarqué sur Twitter et quand il était
invité dans les émissions qu'il avait un
regard sur la société qu'il avait un
avis sur il a un avis surtout et je
pense qu'on va le découvrir dans un
nouveau rôle qui n'est pas celui de
l'animateur tout le monde sait que c'est
un des meilleurs animateurs peut-être le
meilleur dans les années 90 tu vois ce
que je veux dire mais là on va essayer
de le voir il a pris des coups il a été
brûlé par la vie il a des avis c'est pas
le mec de 40 ans tu n'es pas la même
personne il a un peu plus de 60 ans
aujourd'hui il a eu des voilà tu as eu
des coups dans cette intervie plus
personnelle dans ta vie familiale c'est
rien n'a été tout simple et aujourd'hui
il arrive avec un vrai regard sur la
société et là où je l'attends par
exemple moi c'est de le voir face à
Mélenchon je trouve pas Jean-Luc
Mélenchon je l'ai interviewé plein de
fois ça a été assez tendu entre lui et
moi souvent et là de le voir de voir de
proposer quelque chose qu'on a pas vu et
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'il fait flipper
vous savez que ça le fait flipper et ben
oui c'est une bête de guerre donc voilà
mais je pose des questions j'ai pas
envie d'être désagréable mais quand même
je me pose de trois bricoles je suis un
homme je suis un citoyen qui soit pas de
bonne humeur cette semaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc c'est top mais Léa vous avez
participé pour la première fois avec
plaisir première télé c'était vous et je
vous amenez trois fois
[Rires]
donc Laurent Ruquier animé vous êtes
arrivés il est parti vous avez pris la
place est-ce que vous avez envisagé à un
moment que là vous animez Christophe
arrive il est meilleur que vous et il me
dégage
moi si je peux les [ __ ] les deux je le
ferai
[Applaudissements]
je reviendrai tout seul l'année
prochaine je reviens à la maison
on fera des déclarations
quand vous parlez c'était intéressant
vous disiez pendant le pilote j'ai donné
des conseils de producteur j'ai on voit
que le producteur animateur qui est en
vous et dès que ça va démarrer vous
allez reprendre les commandes
j'espère qu'il sera comme ça
je pense que Léa
elle est pas aussi comme c'est pas c'est
pas une animalerie c'est une journaliste
aussi à la base c'est pas pareil je
pense qu'elle peut accepter que
Christophe lui dise des choses voilà
exactement tu vois c'est pas pareil
c'est attention je pense que c'est pour
ça que ça peut fonctionner moi c'est
vrai que voilà je sais que vous dans sur
TPMP people quand je vous donne quelques
conseils c'est vrai que vous le prenez
mal mais Léa je pense qu'elle le prendra
bien non mais c'est vrai Léa je pense
que c'est pas pareil c'est pas ouais
voilà
j'ai vu à évoluer elle est pas là-dedans
je suis une femme aussi ça change
peut-être que les femmes elles ont aussi
des
elle est pas là dedans oui Jean-Michel
tu avais une question
moi je le fais si c'est consenti vous
voyez un conseil
qui est une question une dernière
question j'ai une question de [ __ ]
magazine quand je suis la rédactrice en
chef vous êtes le meilleur animateur de
votre génération est-ce que vous voyez
un successeur un vrai successeur
aujourd'hui
c'est pas un successeur il est déjà
largement largement développé vraiment
vous vous reconnaissez
mais je pense que chacun personnalité
chacun c'est la finalité enfin je veux
dire que personne ne ressemble à Cyril
je ne sais pas si quelqu'un me ressort
non Cyril Féraud ça personnalité
Jean-Pierre
journaliste aussi c'est plus un
journaliste qu'un animateur c'est moi
si je peux si je peux donner à tout ce
que je peux lui donner de tout ce que
j'ai emmagasiné en 30 ou 35 piges je le
fais mais alors vraiment tranquille et
ben en tout cas on a hâte de voir moi
j'ai hâte de voir de vous voir nous
aussi France 2 quelle époque ce sera à
23h10 j'espère 23h10 France 2 pas plus
tard pas de trucs comme ça allez-y
moloqué
je peux pas ça ça va mais ça va me
rendre fou je vais voir les cours qui
vont descendre comme ça ça va m'énerver
je vous le dis ça va m'énerver
il faut démarrer tout de suite après
Cyril Féraud c'est la première France 2
démarrer direct mais c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]